[Applaus]
richter provinz vizepräsident dan harris
sprechen schon mal sehr verehrte gäste
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger dies
ist der tag der vereinigten staaten dies
ist der tag der demokratie
der tag der geschichte und der hoffnung
der erneuerung und der entschlossenheit
amerika ist immer wieder aufs neue auf
die probe gestellt worden und ist immer
wieder der herausforderung begegnet und
heute feiern wir den triumph nicht eines
kandidaten sondern eines anliegens das
anliegen der demokratie die menschen und
der wille der menschen wurde erhört und
der wille der menschen wurde befolgt und
wir haben erneut für uns festgestellt
dass die demokratie nicht nur wertvoll
sondern auch zerbrechlich ist und zu
dieser stunde hat die demokratie jedoch
wieder einmal gesiegt auf die heiligsten
boden sind wir nun nur noch ein paar
tage davon entfernt beziehungsweise sind
nur ein paar tage davon entfernt von all
den dingen die uns so erschüttert hat
aber jetzt sind wir wieder eine nation
unter gott unteilbar um mit den
friedlichen übergang der macht wie seit
mehr als 200 jahren zu vollziehen und
wir schauen in die zukunft auf unsere
ganz eigene amerikanische art und weise
rollos aber auch mutig und optimistisch
und wir konzentrieren uns auf die nation
die wir sein können und von der wir
wissen dass wir sie sein müssen und ich
möchte meinen vorgänger und
vorgängerinnen aus beiden parteien
danken
ich möchte ihnen vom grunde meines
herzens danken
und weiß und ich weiß dass unsere
verfassung widerstandsfähig ist und dass
unsere nation eine starke ist wie auch
präsident carter es gesagt hat mit dem
ich gestern abend sprachen der heute
nicht bei uns sein kann aber denen wir
noch einmal respekt zollen wollen für
seinen leben im öffentlichen dienst und
ich habe gerade einen heiligen eid
abgelegt und das ist der eid den all
diese patrioten abgelegt haben
der zuallererst von george washington
abgelegt worden ist aber die
amerikanische geschichte hängt nicht an
einzelnen von uns hängt nicht an wenigen
von uns sondern von uns allen ab
denn wir sind das volk die eine noch
perfektere einheit anzustreben suchen
das ist eine gute nation und während ein
gutes volk und im laufe der jahrhunderte
sind wir durch belastungen durch frieden
und durch krieg gegangen und haben so
vieles geschafft und wir haben noch so
vieles vor uns und wir werden darauf
hinarbeiten mit druck und mit
dringlichkeiten wir haben in dieser zeit
der großen gefahren und der unabsehbaren
möglichkeiten so vieles noch zu tun
vieles zu reparieren will es wieder
aufzubauen
vieles zu heilen aber auch vieles zu
gewinnen
nur wenige menschen in der geschichte
unseres landes haben größere
herausforderungen vor sich gehabt oder
haben es mit herausfordernden zeiten zu
tun gehabt als den zeiten in denen wir
jetzt leben
ein virus lastet auf unserem land und
hat mehr leben in einem jahr gefordert
als amerika im gesamten zweiten
weltkrieg zu beklagen hatte millionen
arbeitsplätze sind verloren gegangen und
hunderttausende von geschäften müssten
schließen
es gab einen aufschrei für eine
gerechtigkeit der menschen aller
hautfarben der schon seit vielen jahren
und jahrhunderten am braunen war und
hat uns bewegt und das herbeiführen
diese art von gerechtigkeit wird nicht
weiter aufgeschoben werden es ist ein
aufschrei auch ums überleben
dieses planeten den wir jetzt höher und
es ist ein schrei der verzweifelt ein
klarer nicht klingen kann
und in dieser zeit gibt es auch dass
auch kommen politischen extremismus
weiße überlegenheit fantasien und
wünschen terrorismus den wir
entgegentreten und den wir besiegen
werden und müssen um diese
herausforderung zu bewältigen und um die
seele die unseres landes zu bewahren
dafür brauchen wir mehr als nur worte
wir brauchen hierzu das was in der
demokratie vielleicht mit einem flüchtig
ssten ist nämlich einheit einheit im
jahre 1836 hat der gleichberechtigung
und das zeichnet und er hat gesagt wenn
mein name jemals in die geschichte
eingehen wird dann für diesen einen pakt
für diese handlung und ich gebe mich mit
meiner ganzen seele mit meiner ganzen
seele heute an diesem januartag möchte
ich meine gesamte seele hinein geben in
den versuch unser volk zu einem unserer
nationen zu 1 und ich möchte alle
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner dazu
aufrufen mich in diesem vorhaben zu
unterstützen und daran teilzuhaben
[Applaus]
wir müssen uns vereinigen um die feinde
zu bekämpfen mit denen wir es zu tun
haben ärger hass abscheu aber auch
gesetzlosigkeit gewalt wir haben
krankheiten hoffnungslosigkeit und
arbeitslosigkeit zu bekämpfen und mit
unserer einheit können wir großes und
wichtiges erreichen wir können die
fehler der vergangenheit berichtigen wir
können nun arbeitenden menschen gute
arbeit geben wir können unsere kinder in
sicheren schulen unterrichten und wir
können diesen tödlichen virus
wir können die mittelschicht wieder
aufbauen und fallen in unserem land eine
gesundheitsversorgung ermöglichen wir
können für gerechtigkeit wirken und
können amerika wieder einmal zur
führenden kraft des guten in dieser welt
machen
und wenn ich von einheit sprechen dann
klingt das für manche vielleicht wie die
vorstellung die idee eines narren denn
die dinge die uns trennen den tief und
sind sehr real aber ich weiß auch dass
das keine neuen dinge sind unsere
geschichte ist die geschichte eines
andauernden kampfes zwischen dem
amerikanischen ideal nämlich dass wir
alle gleich geschaffen worden sind und
den harschen hässlichen realitäten mit
rassismus natives muss angst
dämonisierung diese realitäten haben uns
sehr lange schon entzweit dieser kampf
dauert ewig und ist nicht sicher
deswegen je gewinnen werden durch die
durch den bürgerkrieg die depression
intrige und nine eleven
wir haben aber trotz all dieser fehl und
rückschläge immer wieder das gute für
uns gewonnen und in all diesen zeiten
sind immer genug von uns in diesem land
zusammengekommen um uns alle
voranzubringen und auch das können wir
jetzt wieder tun
die geschichte der glaube und die
vernunft weisen uns den weg den weg der
einheit wir können einander auch nicht
als gegner sondern als nachbarn
betrachten wir können dann miteinander
mit würde und respekt umgehen wir können
uns zusammenschließen aufhören uns an zu
brüllen und die dinge abkühlen lassen
denn ohne einheit gibt es keinen frieden
nur verbittert und wut keinen
fortschritt sondern nur erschöpfende
empörung
keine nation sondern nur den zustand des
chaos dies ist unsere historische chance
in diesem augenblick der großen krise
führt uns die einheit in die zukunft und
wir müssen in diesem augenblick eben
wieder die vereinigten staaten von
amerika werden und wenn wir das schaffen
dann kann ich garantieren dass wir
erfolgreich sein werden wir haben noch
immer erfolgreich in den usa wenn wir
gemeinsam gehandelt haben
so wie heute zu dieser zeit an diesem
ort
heute sollten wir alle gemeinsam von
vorn beginnen
wir sollten wieder damit beginnen
einander zuzuhören einander zu hören
einander zu sehen und einander respekt
zu zollen
die politik muss nicht immer ein
wütendes feuer sein dass alles in seinem
weg verbrennt und vernichtet auch wenn
man nicht miteinander überein stimmt ist
das nicht unbedingt ein grund für den
totalen krieg wir müssen die kultur
zurückweisen
die in der selbst tatsachen manipuliert
werden oder einfach behauptet liebe
amerikanischen mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger wir sollten anders sein als
dass wir müssen besser sein als das und
ich glaube auch daran dass amerika sehr
viel besser als das ist schauen sie sich
doch einmal um
wir stehen hier im schatten des kapitols
wie es schon angesprochen wurde
wir sind hier an der stelle wo der
bürgerkrieg tobte und als unsere union
hier wirklich auf der kippe stand aber
selbst damals haben wir es geschafft zu
gewinnen und hier stehen wir schauen auf
die mall wo dr
über seinen traum gesprochen hier stehen
wir an dem ort wo vor 108 jahren wären
einen anderen einführungs zeremonie
tausende versucht haben washington und
demonstriert habe das recht und heute
feiern wir das vizepräsident karl-heinz
als erster baut diesen posten antreten
kann
sie können also nicht sagen das ist die
dinge nicht verändern wir stehen hier
gegenüber vom arlington friedhof wo
unsere helden liegen die mit voller
hingabe ihr leben geopfert haben sie
mögen in ewigen frieden ruhen
wir stehen hier nur tage nachdem ein
aufrührerischer mob versucht hat den
willen der menschen zu untergraben und
zu unserer demokratie zu stoppen und uns
von diesem geheiligten boden zu
vertreiben aber das hat nicht
funktioniert es wird nicht stattfinden
weder heute noch morgen nach jemals in
der zukunft niemals und an all jene die
unsere kampagnen unterstützt haben
möchte ich sagen ich möchte mich demütig
dafür bedanken dass sie an uns geglaubt
habt für alle die uns nicht unterstützt
haben möchte ich folgendes sagen hört
uns an und bewertet mich nach meinem
herzen und nach dem was ich sagen und
wenn ihr dann noch nicht mit mir überein
stimmt dann ist das so das ist die
demokratie das ist amerika wir haben das
recht friedfertig anderer meinung zu
sein und das ist vielleicht auch die
größte stärke dieses landes sie hören
mich ganz klar und deutlich das geteilte
meinung nicht dazu führen werden dass
diese union geschwächt oder zerstört und
ich möchte als präsident der präsident
aller amerikanerinnen und amerikaner
sein das verspreche ich ihnen und ich
verspreche ihnen dass sich auch genauso
schwer arbeiten werde für diejenigen die
mich nicht unterstützt haben die für
jene die mich unterstützt und gewählt
haben vor vielen jahrhunderten ein
heiliger meiner kirche gesagt dass die
menschen die masse der menschen sein die
definiert sind durch das
gemeinschaftliche ziel ihrer liebe und
was lieben wir als amerikaner
gemeinschaftlich was definiert uns als
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner nicht
klar aber ist es ganz klar möglichkeiten
zu haben
sicherheit zu haben würde und auch die
wahrheit in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten mussten wir eine schmerzhafte
lektion lernen nicht dass es die
wahrheit gibt und dass es auch lügen
gibt lügen die erzählt werden nur um
sich an der macht und
profi zu bereichern und es ist unsere
und ihr
aber auch unsere als politische
führungspersönlichkeiten die gesagt für
unsere verfassung schützen und
verteidigen wollen unser land schützen
und verteidigen wollen dass wir die
wahrheit ebenso verteidigen müssen und
die lüge zu besiegen hat
b
wer das vieler meiner
damit bürgerinnen die zukunft mit furcht
und zögern vor sich sehen dass die sorge
haben um ihre arbeitsplätze
und das ist menschen gibt die anderen
misstrauen die nicht so aussehen wie
sehen die nicht zu beten wie sie die
vielleicht ihre nachrichten nicht aus
den gleichen quellen beziehen wie sie
wir müssen diesen soja und
bürgerschaftlichen krieg beenden
nicht wahr die ländlichen regionen gegen
die städtischen region konservative
gegen liberale wir werden das schaffen
wenn wir unsere seele öffnen statt
unsere herzen verhärten zu lassen
und wenn wir ein wenig demut und
toleranz an den tag legen und wenn wir
auch bereit sind einmal die position der
anderen und wenn es auch nur für einen
augenblick ist einzunehmen wie meine
mutter dass man zu sagen pflegte denn
wissen sie das ist die sache mit dem
leben man kann einfach nicht wissen was
einem das schicksal zuteil werden lässt
und manchmal brauchen sie eine helfende
hand und dann gibt es wieder tage wo sie
aufgerufen sind eine helfende hand
auszustrecken
das ist genau das wer wir sind und was
wir für einander leistungen und wenn wir
so sind dann wird unser land gestärkt
werden wird's wohlhabender sein und
bereit sein für die zukunft und trotzdem
können wir nun
die amerikanisch mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürgern in der arbeit die vor uns
liegt brauchen vereinen dann brauchen
wir unsere stärke um durch diesen stunde
winter hindurch zu kommen und das ist
jetzt der härtesten vielleicht
tödlichste abschnitt dieser virus
epidemie und wir müssen eben endlich
diesem virus auch als eine geeinte
nation entgegentreten und ich möchte
ihnen folgendes versprechen wie es in
der bibel heißt das dass trauern
vielleicht eine nacht wohl anhalten wird
aber dass am morgen schon die freude auf
uns warteten dass wir gemeinsam durch
diese situation hindurch kommen werden
neben damen und herren alle meine
kolleginnen und kollegen mit denen ich
hier im haus und im senat gearbeitet
haben wir verstehen alle und wissen dass
die welt auf uns schaut auf uns alle wie
heute und deswegen diese botschaft an
jene außerhalb unserer grenzen amerika
wurde auf die probe gestellt aber wir
sind stärker aus dieser situation heraus
gegangen wir werden unsere allianzen
reparieren und wir werden mit der welt
wieder zusammenarbeit nicht um auch die
herausforderung von gestern sondern auf
die von morgen zu reagieren und wir
werden nicht nur durch unsere macht
führen sondern durch die macht die wir
als beispiel abgeben
[Applaus]
wir wollen ein starker und
vertrauenswürdiger partner für
fortschritt für frieden und für die
sicherheit seien
sie wissen dass wir selbst in dieser
nation sehr viel durchgemacht haben und
mein erster handlung als präsident ist
folgende ich möchte sie bitten mit mir
ein stilles gebet abzuhalten um all
derer zu gedenken die wir im vergangenen
jahr die pandemie verloren haben diese
400.000 amerikanischen mitbürger
mitbürger mütter väter
freunde kollegen nachbarn und
nachbarinnen wir möchten sie ehrlich um
das volk und die nation zu werden von
der wir wissen dass wir sie sein können
und damit möchte ich sie bitten jetzt
mit mir ein stilles gebet für jene zu
sprechen
die ihr leben verloren haben im dienste
für unser land und in dieser pandemie
dies ist die zeit einer prüfung wir
sehen wie unsere demokratie angegriffen
wird wie die wahrheit angegriffen hat
wie ein virus wollte wie es wachsende
ungleichheit gibt wie es systemischen
rassismus gibt und es gibt auch noch die
klimakrise und all diese probleme werden
für sich genommen schon eine große
herausforderung aber tatsache ist dass
wir diese herausforderungen gleichzeitig
begegnen müssen deswegen haben wir in
dieser nation ist eine der
schwerwiegendsten verantwortung
überhaupt wir werden auch wieder geprüft
werden entweder wir müssen alle unsere
anstrengungen
wir müssen einfach an unsere
anstrengungen hochfahren das ist eine
zeit der mutigen schritte und eines ist
sicher ich verspreche ihnen dass wir
danach beurteilt werden sie und ich wie
wir diese kaskadieren krisen bewältigt
wir werden uns diesen problemen stellen
die frage ist werden wir in dieser
schwierigen zeit das schaffen dieses
problem zu bewältigen werden wir es
schaffen unseren kindern eine neue
bessere welt weiter zu geben
ich glaube wir müssen das und ich glaube
sie glauben das auch und ich glaube wir
werden es schaffen
und wenn wir das tun dann werden wir das
nächste große kapitel in der geschichte
der vereinigten staaten schreiben der
geschichte amerikas der geschichte die
vielleicht sich wie ein lied anhört aber
mir so viel bedeutet und das findet sich
wieder im markt
dort gibt es eine strophe dient wirklich
noch einmal besonders ist sie geht
sinngemäß worden
die arbeit und die gebete der
jahrhunderte haben uns zu diesem tag
geführt was soll nun unser erbe sein was
werden unsere kinder sagen lasst mich in
meinem herzen spüren wenn meine tage
vorüber sind amerika amerika ich habe
mein bestes für dich gegeben
und wir sollten nun unsere arbeit und
unsere gebete der sich entwickelten
geschichte unserer großartigen nation
hinzufügen und wenn wir das schaffen
dann werden wir am ende unserer tage
unseren kindern und kindeskindern
tatsächlich sagen können uns unsere
kinder werden sagen können sie haben ihr
bestes getan und sie haben ein
gebrochenes land geheilt und das wird
mich zurück zu anfang nämlich dem
geheiligten eid den ich abgelegt habe
und vor ihnen und vor gott möchte ich
ihnen mein wort dafür geben dass sich
mit ihnen immer ehrlich sein werde dass
sich die verfassung verteidigen werde
unsere demokratie verteidigen werde
und auch die vereinigten staaten von
amerika verteidigen werde
und ich möchte ihnen allen alles
anbieten um ihnen dienen zu können nicht
bis auf die macht und auf die sich ihr
bietenden möglichkeiten konzentrieren
ein gemeinsam mit ihnen möchte ich die
amerikanische geschichte hoffnung nicht
der angst stand der einheit nicht
erteilung des lichtes nicht der
dunkelheit die geschichte der
anständigkeit der würde der liebe und
der heilung das großartig und es gut
möge dies die geschichte sein die uns
führt die geschichte die uns inspiriert
und die geschichte die den noch zu uns
auflaufen folgenden generationen
erzählen wird dass wir im richtigen
augenblick auf den herausforderungen der
geschichte reagiert haben dass die
hoffnungen dass die wahrheit und die
gerechtigkeit unter unseren augen nicht
gestorben ist sondern bemüht hat und das
den vereinigten staaten wieder einmal
zum leuchtfeuer der welt aufgestiegen
ist das ist das was unsere vorfahren
angestrebt haben und was die folgenden
generationen weiter getragen haben mit
entschlossenheit wenden wir uns dieser
großen aufgabe unserer zeit zu getragen
durch unseren glauben
angetrieben durch unsere überzeugung
gemeinsam mit allen anderen in diesem
land das wir lieben mit ganzem herzen
möge gott die vereinigten staaten segnen
und unsere truppen schützen
vielen dank
[Applaus]